[Music]
riverdale star lily reinhardt has just
spoken about her decision to come out as
bisexual
in a new interview with flaunt magazine
lily said she
always knew she was attracted to women
and those closest to her
knew as well lily told font i knew full
well that i was attracted to women from
a young age
i felt that since i've exclusively been
in heteronormative relationships it
would be too easy for any outsider
especially the media to vilify me and
accuse me of faking it to get
attention lily first came out back in
june
after posting an instagram story
promoting a lgbtq plus
for black lives matter protest in
hollywood california
lily also spoke about what it felt like
to be with the lgbtq plus community
at the protest lily said it was
incredible to be surrounded by so many
people who are
actively fighting against the injustices
that are happening right now
enough is enough and hopefully we'll see
some real change from the actions that
are now being taken
and last night tmz caught up with lily
who was with her dad and she said it's
time for the media to reflect
what the real world looks like even on
disney channel
she's right about that
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos